Joanna there is a study that shows one in 60 dads end up
raising a child that doesn't belong to him. So non paternity is obviously an,
an issue of fairly high prevalence in United States in general and possibly
the world in, in general. How does 23andMe deal with issues of non paternity?
>> So this is certainly a big issue for 23andMe
Because it's one of the most high impact results that someone
who signed up for 20, for 23andMe can
get. and before people sign up it's very important
that they consider the possibility of making a
discovery about biological relationships in their family that they
didn't previously know about. And so. And that's
why, when we launched the service from the very
beginning, we in our terms of service we said, be a, a, a, you should be aware
that you may learn things about yourself that,
that, you find uncomfortable, that are disturbing. Including that
your biological father, is not your biological father. The
person that you know to be your father is
not your biological father. So we were very
explicit from the very beginning that this is a
possibility. so that, The people are aware that that
is something that can come out of DNA analyses.
>> And so, are people. Do you, do you find many
people not aware that the personal genetic services offered at 23? I
mean, is essentially, in a way, can be like a paternity test.
>> Well, many, organizations that do official paternity
testing are doing it in a way that, the evidence will hold up in court.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> So it's a bit, a bit of
a different process. So, for 23andMe customers, it's more
like something they just discover. right when they're
exploring their data. And the main way that people
discover an opportunity is if they find that their
genetic relationship to another family member is not what
they had anticipated. That that they are instead
of being a full sibling with someone they think
is their sibling, they're a half sibling, because they
have different fathers. So that's not an unusual. And,
One, resource that we provide, is, we provide a forum, a discussion forum. where
many of our customers, put out their, questions to other members of the 23andMe
community. And that's where we've seen evidence
of, people discovering non-paternity. And very often
they have questions like how do I check to find out whether this is
true or not? How do I handle conversations with other members of my family? And
other members of the 23andMe community often come forward with advice on,
you know, who else should be tested in the family. How do, you know, approach.
other family members and I've seen
people reporting cases where they've said, I'm not going to tell my dad that
I've discovered this because he's been my dad all my life and
and there's no need for us to change that
>> Sure I, I imagine.
>> And so people make these big
personal decisions once they get this, this information.